cette plante médicinale porte décidément
bien son nom le changer corse on
l'appelle également le goyave marron en
raison de sa ressemblance avec le
goyavier parmi les 835 espèces végétales
indigènes de la réunion ce petit arbuste
qu'on retrouve dans les forêts de bois
de couleur s'est développée sur l'île
bien avant l'arrivée de l'homme
mais les anciens se sont très vite
approprié les vertus médicinales
présentes dans ces petites feuilles
dampier là un petit peu de bois clé
apprécié aussi doha tisanerie d'elle
c'est le brouillard marron rien à voir
avec le brouillard peut-être peut-il
ressemblance et petits fruits blancs ou
les feuilles
oui à maroney notre nom c'est 100 et
corse quand les vielles le pied ils
perdent les corses se tenir loin des
côtes il fit tomber les gros les corps
qui tombent donc il laisse le pied un
peu de couleur blanche at jaunâtre donc
sans écosse où liam aaron c'est un petit
pic bois qui pousse son attitude dans
toutes les forêts de l'île des eaux ou
trouve un petit gamin on à petit le
groupe william aaron très apprécié comme
rafraîchissante de william aaron on
utilise les feuilles et donc on va
prendre les petites feuilles de williams
à un petit cadenas honte comme ça la
seule petite tisane pour un bison un bon
litre à bouillir soi tout seul
cinq six sept feuilles soient à bouillir
avec un petit peu de
barman de fleurs jaunes ou à bouillir
racine et de feuilles de fraises qui
ferait 10 pouces dans la forêt que
dominés apprécie bien pas fraises
crapaud mais bon petit fraises que les
bien sucré qui pousse dans les autres tu
trouvais mon peu maïdo avant ou dans les
autres il a aussi tout encore un peu tu
avais sentiers de randonnées dont le
gouverneur ont très connu ici pour ses
vertus refranchi rafraîchissante
très utilisée associée avec d'autres
plantes ou tout seul avant de gaz car
les appeler le voit footsie louis a
marre on sait la boisson nationale
bonnet bois ça régulièrement il voit ça
tous les jours
ça aide pour le palu 17 pour éviter ou
poulets fier pas l'idéal donc voix
footsie à madagascar c'est la famille
mêmes familles mêmes qu'on aille chine
rappelle sakuya baron voilà ça c'est un
petit pied que nenê a quand même dizaine
douzaine d'années on a planté quelques
william aaron souterrain mélina bon paix
dans nos banlieues de la ravine et il
pousse facilement dans la cour et les
jolies dans leur ampleur
une préparation décoction là nous va
prendre de fraude que les la nouvelle
wii noire et dans cette bouilloire en
même temps nous va mettre des plantes
décoction de jean baptiste est désormais
vide et fumeterre dans ma ville et papa
que l'aco l'avait lanouf et un petit peu
de plantes comme ça pour à peu près un
litre et demi un litre un litre et demi
s'est dit bien décoction pour le bain
litres un litre et demi ne peut rajouter
un peu trop propre
regarde bien box et aux phoques est au
top en maille qui connaît pas trop pour
que ces pays pauvres qui touchent à
leurs caveaux corps mais pas dans
n'importe quel cas on compte parce
qu'anna poison par les producteurs donc
veillez bien à ne pas ramasser n'importe
rouge le propos très bon pour le
psoriasis très bon pour les problèmes de
peau lanouf un petit peu par ici on ne
peut rajouter là dans d'autres plans
mais là c'est pour montrer comment nous
fait une décoction donc nous la verse
l'eau nous a versé 12 dans l'eau est
froide ne batte les plans dedans nous
recouvre casserole le voir comment ça se
fait dans une grande envie donner vos
casseroles ne fait ça pour 5 10 vite là
c'est démonstration de chauffe nous
lasse de l'eau bouillante la décoction
dans cinq 5 minutes 10 minutes
attention les corps de muammar on les
paie faire revenir à ne pas utiliser
utiliser les feuilles mais pas les
conséquences et vomitif un petit peu de
bois ces résistants un joli petit peu de
bois les files et bruyant et y pousse
facilement dans un jardin allez hop on
dans les bras